could diversity take away from your
creativity as well okay I current ago
that I think um I think the critical
thing is stay true to your idea straight
to your mission your purpose that that's
fundamental less your foundation but
within that then the next question is
how do you reach audience and then also
how do you do it how do you go to market
how do you create the product I think by
including diverse do you actually
increase the level of creativity
dramatically and the financial results
are companies that are strong and
diverse tend to be way better than those
that are very restrictive and
traditional now I think why does it
increase diversity you know if again it
Spotify is really cool they have they
have this music room and then they have
this area where they can watch people or
focus groups and stuff like that and
they deliberately will get very diverse
people listening to their new products
and that she going through the whole
usability their new products and you
okay because I'm I guess I've lived in
technology long time you cannot believe
how great engineers don't realize how
difficult to use their products are and
they might have built the best you know
mousetrap in the world they mount and
build the best features of functions of
the coolest kind of music download in
the world but unless it's usable and
simple and intuitive then it's not going
to get our the air time so they you
never ever ever arm get disappointed by
getting user feedback in terms of Rho
testing new products and i think around
that you don't want to just rotate
unless you've got a very narrow part
just to one segment of society it's much
better if you really want to scare your
product to do that and then go out to
other segments and be very diverse and
you're thinking I think the creativity
just is speaking for me personally by
having a lot of people within the
company challenge me from very diverse
backgrounds
gives me a much greater appreciation of
how to do the best for our customers so
and again you know it's so true in life
sometimes I think there's an
entrepreneur you get a bit successful
you start believing your own PR are and
you get a bit comfortable and when you
do that you kind of lose your creativity
whereas what were your questions all
about coke is about how do you
accelerate their creative in their I
think diversity is just one of the ways
you can do that and get some fantastic
input sent really strong invention
innovation and then there's a lady kind
of going to make the choices and start
executing and delivering on that vision
yeah I'm definitely steven on this one I
don't know that we just really disagree
a lot though and the questions anyway
just different sides of the coin on most
of these I don't see a world in which
for any company adding diversity would
take away from creativity just I don't
know how that happens I think maybe
maybe your own you know if you're
injecting other people into a company
then maybe the responsibility on you
isn't as great to be creative if you
have to come up with everything then now
that you have people you can rely on
maybe you don't have to compass as many
ideas maybe your own personal creativity
I don't know if that's what he's getting
that but you know look at what's in the
best interest of your company the best
ideas when if it's only you coming up
with ideas and the ideas are just ok by
adding more people into the mix they can
take that ok idea into a great one and
so if that means you're not coming up
with every single idea for the business
and maybe that's a good thing to help
you get to where you need to go